in this video I'll be going over an
example of the distributive law so if
you look at a intersection B Union C
that is supposed to equal a intersection
B Union a intersection C so if we can if
we decompose this equation and look at
let's start with a intersection B then
that equals singleton 3 based off from
these predetermined sets and then if we
look at a intersection C that equals the
set 1 3 so the union of these two is
going to be the set containing elements
1 & 3 now if we look at B Union C that
equals the set containing elements 1 3
beta and gamma and if we take the
intersection of that set with a we're
left with a set containing elements 1 &
3 which is good because now we've shown
that this that now if we look at a union
B intersection C that's suppose equal a
union B intersection a union C so for
you analyze B intersection C that equals
singleton 3 and then a UV p right here
equals 1 3 X beta gamma in a union C
equals the set containing elements 1 3
and X so when we take the intersection
of these two sets
we're left with the set containing
elements 1 3 and X and when we take the
union of B intersection C with a we're
left with the second taining elements 1
3 and X which is exactly what we want it
so yeah we've shown that these are in
fact true